heathyr my name's Tom Wickham Jones and
I work at Wolfram research and I'm
giving a talk about the Wolfram compiler
which is a new development project for
working with and implementing the
Wolfram language and compiling out to
external code and making the code run
run faster and adding all sorts of great
features so the purpose of a compiler or
definition it's maybe a system to
translate computer source code from one
programming language to another often
it's going from a set of high-level
language to a lower level language some
of the benefits of compilation you can
get faster executions so the lower level
language might be simpler and faster and
the translation process itself might
might sort of optimize add optimizations
like removing unused code and stuff like
that it can work with other and emerging
technologies multi-core other compilers
GPUs you can get all sorts of
verification warnings understanding
problems to you know might you you wrote
the code in some way that you didn't
necessarily intend and the compiler can
give you some warnings about that and it
can help in cleaning and tidying code so
Mathematica is had a compiler since
version 2 Mathematica introduced in 1991
so quite a long time ago
and it's it's a very popular part a lot
of people reach to the compiler to try
to sort of speed up the the execution of
their code and I'm not going to go
through all the sort of history of
compile or show how it works but it's
been developed steadily over the years
the last last big set of X improvement
was in version 8 when we added some some
cogeneration and parallel execution
features and a way of dynamically
generating shared libraries
get get sort of faster faster execution
so since then I kind of thought that
there's a lot of power and compile but
it also has a lot of weaknesses and here
are some of the weaknesses that you know
it only works can't compile only works
for simple types like like machine
integer or machine real and it doesn't
support things like strings or
Association and it doesn't support big
number 16 bit unsigned integers you
can't add new types doesn't support
function types and things that come with
with function types doesn't integrate
with the pattern matcher the
implementation was it's hard to extend
doesn't really use sort of modern
knowledge about compilers and modern
technologies and it's kind of limited it
does have a cogeneration feature but
that's pretty limited and it's not not a
very natural feature and that that's
that's kind of why it's limited so
what's the solution
so the solution has been to start on a
totally new implementation of of compile
and this is long term project and one of
the things it's entirely built from the
Wolfram language so one of the language
features that was added that was kind of
gave this a big impetus and a big kick
was the addition of the association
feature that came in and an association
actually was version 10 or whenever it's
been a powerful feature and I know from
talking to a bunch of users in all sorts
of other areas that it's it's it's added
a lot of Rev to the to the Wolfram
language so the general code flow that
we get I'm gonna have to shrink this now
you don't have to read all of this but
this is kind of the flow that we trying
to scale this
[Music]
also scroll over so we start with
mathematical code and we we go through
some D sugaring phase where we rewrite
the code and we add various
transformations but on at the Wolfram
language code level then we translate
into an intermediate representation and
this is something that's more written in
the technology of compilers we do type
type inferencing to add type annotations
then we generate a we go through a
technology called LLVM to generate us at
a target code and then we have something
that can be executed so I'll try and
show you some of these sorts of steps so
here I'm compiling out to the sort of
intermediate representation this is the
sort of untyped I might just shrink the
size so we've taken a a Wolfram language
program so this is a a function like a
sort of lambda function in Mathematica
it's been given type annotations for the
input types and then this is the sort of
pseudocode the Wolfram intermediate
representation that that comes out of it
and then we have a bunch of ways of
looking at it
so this is another showing some of the
sort of graph so there's a there's an if
statement so in we have the if and it's
the true case or the false case and then
it comes together at this sort of final
part here then we have another
representation so we take that
representation and we add type
annotations and we also do some sort of
expansions to target things like there's
a there are arithmetic plus plus
operations here and so we've added
instructions here to get the target this
sort of the runtime functions and we can
see here that we've
added you know the sort of various
various type so everything has a type
all the way through and at the very end
we're returning an I so this is
returning an integer and up here we have
a markup that's saying we have integer
to our two integer arguments and the
return value is an integer so then we
have a next next stage with this and
this is where we're jumping to this LLVM
technology you know I'll talk about this
and this is another representation but
this is kind of the entry point into a
tool chain
that's called LLVM and this is kind of
like a platform independent assembler
code and it can be interpreted but it
can also be converted further and so
LLVM is a now sort of really you know
it's kind of like the leading technology
for implementing compilers so the VM is
kind of a bit confusing because it's not
a virtual machine in the way that the
JVM is a virtual machine LLVM is like
GCC it's like it's a compiler set of
technologies but it's a more modern and
it's it's designed specifically to be a
set of some reusable components that
sort of work together it's the basis of
the clang C C++ compiler it actually
comes from here from from the U of I I
think that's where the original work
came but it's now been picked up by many
companies and it really is a little
merging standard for language support
and there's tons of tools that work with
LLVM like debuggers and transformers and
profilers and there are translators into
other other languages like javascript
the inscription project and it
integrates with GPUs so one of the
things that we can do with LLVM is we
can generate output code so here i've
generated a compile the far
action and I've got something where I
can execute it so here I'm I'm actually
executing you know the sort of native
assembler code on the on the machine so
this is kind of a useful powerful way to
go so it's I haven't gone through an
object file and a library and a linker
I've just gone direct to a certain
layout of assembler in memory so that's
that's that's that's that's kind of
useful so I showed you the the
intermediate code so we see that that
kind of here and in order so one of the
details of this is in order to to call
this you see this is taking an integer
but we're coming from Mathematica from
the kernel and we have a different data
type we have expressions and so the
solution to this is we generate a a
wrapper function and this is a bit more
complicated but here's the so this is
the function that we want to call and
this is the function that we can call
from the kernel and so this is taking
like an expo struct and it's doing
various transformations to sort of pull
out do checking you know we check hard
to see this but you you know we're we're
checking to see if the checking this
takes one integer so we're checking the
length is one and checking that it's an
integer and then down here we're
actually calling the function unless
some other sort of cleanup of this so
this is kind of a key part of the
cleverness is that we can generate this
this function dynamically so for those
of you work with library link this this
is also applicable to library link
because we're instead of writing you
having to write an interface thing that
sits in the middle we can now generate
this automatically so this is kind of
the idea here's the kernel and this is
the function that we want to call and
we've created this sort of
a thing that sits sits in the middle so
and this this feature of generating code
that we're injecting into the sort of
pipeline is is is is kind of a sort of
powerful part of this and that's that's
that's that's kind of thing so you know
what can we do with this intermediate
representation I showed how we can
execute it or something but here for
example I've converted it into the
native assembler for the platform so
it's like you know Pentium but one of
the nice things about LLVM is it's very
good at cross cross compilation so here
i've generated arm arm instructions so
if I was on an ARM processor I could
execute that and then here I'm I can
generate CUDA so this is this is you
know code that could execute on on the
GPU so I'm not going to talk a lot about
CUDA I don't talk anymore about CUDA in
the talk today but on Friday Abdul is
giving a talk where he's talking much
more about running the compiler and
targeting the you know this sort of you
know the the GPU to execute sort of
native code so another thing that you
can do is I can export this to an object
file
all right I've actually I already Ori
did this once but so I just execute
export it to an object file and there's
the this is the that's that's the but
you know the the object file so this
this file I could then go and write a C
program or some other language and I
could link it to this file here and this
shows one of the amazing benefits of
using LLVM is that I just did this like
on Monday morning and it took me about
20 minutes to take the IR code and write
it you know write it out because there's
a tool in LLVM that does that so in the
old compile we added a code generator
that did the same thing and it took us
you know a
two or three months to code up the
generating C code invoking the compiler
compiling it generating the object file
so a considerably more considerably you
know if I say to you you can take 20
minutes or you can take three months I
think you'll take the you know the the
shorter route and that shows the benefit
of working with existing existing
technologies yes well that that file
there is completely I mean like I said
it's just well you can see what it does
I mean it I mean it's not doing very
much well you need to satisfy all the
functions that you're gonna call of
course so right so you you need to have
you know you you'd need to have code for
that so I'll talk about that a little
bit a little little little bit later so
now I want to talk about the type system
so the the old compiler had a fixed set
of types they were like boolean machine
integer machine real machine complex and
things that we call pat arrays so they
were tensors and integer real and
complex and that was it there was
nothing else so one things we really
wanted was to have a more flexible type
system and so some of the benefit you
know white why do you want types so they
are it's a type system is in a sense
it's a an additional programming
language that you impose on top of your
your your your code and it gets executed
at compilation time and if the execution
of this language fails it tells you
there's something wrong so it's a way of
avoiding bugs and strange unintended
code and the type system is a lot of
gives you a lot of introspection
abilities so it helps you to give
correctness to Surrey right
an optimized code and one of the ways
that's that's been understood and it's
understood increasingly now is the type
system itself if you make you know with
adding the right features and generic
types is it's on the features it's
another layer of abstraction in your
code that gives you sort of more
flexibility so you can write less code
and do more with it so that's that's
some of the sort of benefits so in in
the new compile we've in fact we have a
general of pretty general type system
that where we can create types and add
them and so on and we've added you know
a bunch of native types boolean bunch of
different signed and unsigned sizes
we've got compound types obviously sort
of packed arrays but we have other other
types of compound things as well we have
function types strings expert and
parametric types so that's a little look
at this so I'm just going to show this
would be like a native integer here's a
32-bit integer this would be a compound
type kind of like a packed array so this
is a packed array of Rank 1 Rank 2 of of
integers this would be this is the sort
of input syntax and then we're creating
this would be a function type that takes
an integer and returns another integer
and here we have a this is a generic
type so this is a function that takes
one argument and returns a type of that
same argument but we haven't said what
what that type is so this is this is a
class of functions that could take a
real - a real or a string - a string or
whatever so for example if you had an
identity function would have what would
would would have this this this this
type
so one of the things about the types is
we have this sort of hierarchy of type
and this is how we add functionality to
the system so for example the integer
type we have these things called
subtypes or type classes not the same
thing as classes in Java or C++ it's not
not the same thing so so like the
integer type implements a bunch of them
all like interfaces and so we made a
actually this we use this
for debugging and understanding what
we're creating so we have this sort of
type report that tells us what so here's
these are this sort of you know sort of
a Tom atomic built-in sorry concrete
types so these are the types that you
can actually use in you know pass around
as variables so this is like a 64-bit
integer which sort of appears down here
and these are all the type classes that
that it implements so the the value of
these abstract types or type classes is
that we can attach code to them and so
anything that implements the abstract
type will pick up the implementation of
that function so for example we have the
floating type signature so like many of
the real types and so that would be like
real 32 or real 64 or complex implement
the the floating and so it picks up you
know all of these functions like like
sort of exponential and you know we have
you know different different sorts of
types so that's that's how we've you
know the sort of type system a lot of
these things you don't really have to
sort of worry about but that's that's
that's kind of kind of works so another
aspect of type is we want to add type
signatures to the functions when we do
this through what's called type
unification so here I've got a function
type so I've got this is if I'm
that takes an integer to an integer and
I want to match this with another
function where I know what the input is
but I I don't know what the output is so
I do unification and I get the
substitutions and the substitutions are
saying that the this output variable is
a real and then we could go and apply
these substitutions and the result is a
function type that map's integer to real
so this is how we do you know sort of
type inferencing so and this is done
like like in the Wolfram I R so this is
done for example here's the here's a
function so we have you undefined for
all the types and then we run a type
inference saying pass on the thing and
it's done this sort of unification for
the function and it's it's it's added
this the sort of appropriate type
annotations right let's keep going so
but why why do we have a type system at
all I mean the Wolfram language is
typeless it's based on generic general
expressions the the expression type and
on the other hand this this is quite
beneficial as well it saves on a coding
time you don't have to think too too
much about this so why why do we have
that so the solution that we've worked
for here is to integrate expressions
into the type system so here I'm writing
the function and I've said that the
argument but the argument here is a a
general those two arguments but they're
general they're experts so I can call
these with with integers and I get the
result but I can call this with symbolic
input and I get the you know this sort
of you know it's calling a plus operator
here I'm calling it with so to sum some
big numbers and I get back you know this
sort of result so this is working in the
compiler system to get more to work with
expressions and what are the expressions
can can be kind of useful when we go to
integrate with the Wolfram system so
the old system we would just run compile
and we get back a compiled function so
that's what this compiled to external
function is doing but in the new system
we can do things like I can write a
function and then I can do compile
function and now that's added an
annotation to that pure function that
uses the compiled code so it works in
the same this one is the compiled one
and this is the uncompelled one so then
if I use this function so like in a
function like the sort function it it
executes with the this sort of optimized
code and actually this is really nice
it's always bugged me that you know if I
give a sorting function to sort it
executes more slowly and experienced
mathematical programmers of which there
are lot in this room know all sorts of
tricks that you can do to sort of if you
want to sort of use the sort of Naturals
you know the built-in sorting function
but have more complicated data so but
this is you know you don't need to do
that you just compile the thing and you
get you know it's getting quite close to
the you know this sort of natural
sorting so that's that's kind of a nice
sort of workflow and here's another one
which which is kind of a neat thing is
this is kind of new so it's not really
working but the idea here is to compile
actual down values so this is so I'm
taking a function written as you would
with pattern matching you know colon
equals and now I'm compiling the
functions and it's generated and this is
one where I've got an implementation one
function here is calling another
function and then when I compile this
it's generated this sort of pseudo code
which I could then push out and and
execute but this one here you see this
is this function here is calling this
function here so this is not going
through the pattern matcher this is just
making a direct call kind of as you
would in if you've written a C program
to do this so this is kind of
as sort of a neat thing or if you had
another version of this so I've added
type annotations and now the the
function that I've generated is going to
going going to come out and if I save
then to me you know I could write this
to the object file so this this one here
is using functions for the runtime but
but it'll it'll pull those into the
intermediate representation that you
write out so I could compile this and
link it and and it would work so that's
kind of a neat thing you've never really
been able to do that to write
complicated programs with different
functions calling each other and save
them out in a way that could be executed
outside of outside the system so that's
that's that's kind of a nice a nice
feature I won't talk about to run time
we've got a big powerful runtime this is
another new feature that we added quite
recently and this is having sort of
nested functions so here I've got one
function and inside of it I've got
another function that I'm using and so
we co generate this and it all sort of
executes and and and and works or here's
a more complicated I'm gonna generate
the the output code so it so it all sort
of executes sin in the way that now this
is really important because being able
to pass round functions as data like
this is needed if you want to do
parallel programming you need to
generate intermediate functions and then
use them in your code to do to do
parallel processing so this will open up
a whole new suite of parallel
computation that's that's not really
being possible previously so no that's
that's I maybe should have turned off
turned off it thinks that these
arguments are kind of repeated in some
way so no yeah this this one here is
conflicting with this one I would guess
so yeah right this is new syntax that's
not added to the syntax coloring system
right so I think I probably need to wrap
up since I'm I'm coming so this is kind
of a
just quick summaries so the compiler
it's the sort of pipeline of compilation
and we go through working with
expressions and then generating
intermediate representation going into
LLVM ir and then and then getting
getting sort of executable code we have
a sort of type system and you know as we
go to the release the things that we're
looking to do is you know things like
the the down values computation
even for the implementation of the
pattern matcher for many types of
patterns we can actually generate code
like that wrapper function and then we
can compile that and and execute that
and that that that that would be a
really powerful way to avoid having you
know when you write your code even if
you're calling the evaluator for the
body of your code you could select which
which patterns to use whether with a
program that you you don't write we we
write that and so this is a faster way
to to access your your to access your
code that would be helpful if you had
like small little functions so all sorts
of optimizations integrations or
technologies and generating standalone
code so I think this is kind of an
exciting technology thanks very much
[Applause]